>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> I'm Jan Lauridsen.
This is my colleague
over here Anne McLean.
We both work in the Music
Division here in the Library
of Congress, and this
morning we're going to talk
about some very precious items
from the music collections,
among them two crown jewels,
Cantata Number 9, the manuscript
of Cantata number 9 and
number 10 In Bach's Hand.
They're hardly ever taken out
of the vault and put on display.
So, all of us really
are very privileged
to have this opportunity
to study them up close.
Let's start with
Cantata Number 9:
"Es ist das Heil uns
Kommen her", which means,
salvation has come to us.
The term "Cantata" is
associated with Bach
because he wrote
hundreds of them mostly
for Lutheran church services.
Most of them date to his time
in Leipzig when he was cantor
of St. Thomas Church and
was also in charge of music
at the other main Lutheran
churches in Leipzig,
St. Nicholas, St. Peter
and the New Church.
By the way, Bach
was elected cantor
by the Leipzig town
council 294 years ago today
on April 22nd, 1723.
As cantor, it was Bach's
job to prepare cantatas
for every Sunday and holiday
church service; too loud, okay,
which would add up to
60 plus cantatas a year.
Three more or less complete
full-year cycles of cantatas
by Bach have survived, but
he may have composed as many
as five with most of
the last two being lost.
Bach's performances required
that musicians be extremely
well-trained and versatile,
because Bach expected
a lot of them.
The town pipers and art
fiddlers including woodwind,
string and brass
players were proficient
of several instruments each.
They were the best musicians in
Leipzig and the most well paid.
The singers were mostly students
and alumni of St. Thomas School.
On entry, Bach would
rank the best singers
as having a good voice, a
fine voice, a strong voice,
or a good, strong voice.
Having reliably fine
musicians was essential
to Bach the composer.
Comparing his own music to that
of other composers, he said,
"The concerto pieces that are
performed by the first choir
which are mostly of my own
composition are incomparably
harder and more intricate."
This is a lovely watercolor of
St. Thomas Church and school
where Bach and family lived
painted by Felix Mendelssohn
from the vantage point of
his apartment when he lived
in Leipzig about a
hundred years after Bach.
A typical Bach cantata is
a multipart polyphonic work
for vocal soloists,
instrumentalists and choir
with texts that relates
to the Bible readings
in the Lutheran liturgy for a
particular Sunday or holiday.
As "Es ist das Heil uns kommen
her" is a chorale cantata,
meaning that the music
incorporates the tune
of a Lutheran corral or hymn
and the text incorporates
versus of the hymn, sometimes
verbatim, sometimes paraphrased.
Bach wrote more than
50 chorale cantatas.
"Es ist das Heil" is based
on a hymn by Paul Speratus,
a Catholic priest who
became a Protestant preacher
and hymn writer.
He and Martin Luther wrote the
First Lutheran hymnal published
in 1524 known as
the "Achliederbuch"
"Book of Eight" songs.
The overall subject of the hymn
is justification by faith alone.
Some of the text can be
translated as "Works never help.
They cannot protect us.
Lord, instead of good works
you look at the strength
of faith in our hearts.
Only faith justifies us."
The composer of the chorale
tune itself is not known.
It is cited as a
traditional German Easter tune
that dates back to around 1400.
"Est ist das Heil" was composed
sometime between 1732 and 1735
for the Sixth Sunday
after Trinity which falls
in late July or early August.
The cantata is in seven parts.
As is typical of a
chorale cantata, the first
and last movements are based
on the chorale, both the tune
and the text and the middle
sections are recitatives
and arias which mostly
paraphrase the chorale text.
Here is the first of
the seventeen pages
which comprise the manuscript.
Originally, there were four
folios that were folded
into bifolios resulting
in four pages each.
It goes like this, you
know, one, two, three, four.
So, there are four of them.
Bach added an additional
page after he crossed
out a messy version of the
last recitative and rewrote it
on a clean page, and you can
see it a little bit later.
Across the top, Bach wrote
"JJ Jesu juva", "Jesus help",
"Jesus help me crank
out one more cantata."
Bach always wrote "JJ" at the
beginning and "Deo soli gloria"
for the "glory of God
alone" at the very end
of his music for worship.
Continuing across the top,
"Dominica 6 post Trinitatis."
That's the Sixth
Sunday after Trinity,
"Es ist das Heil uns
kommnen her" for four voices,
in transverse flute, one
[foreign word spoken],
or oboe d' amore, two
violins, viola and continuo.
I know it's a travesty to play
little clips of a blind piece
of music by Bach, but we can't
just talk about the manuscript.
We have to, we have to hear
the at some of the cantata.
This is a recording
by Helmuth Rilling
and Back Collegium
Stutgart made in 1985.
The first clip is the beginning
of the cantata which is a kind
of contrapuntal fantasy
based on the chorale tune.
I'll play enough of it so that
you can hear the sopranos come
in with the chorale to and in
long, you know, sustained notes.
You'll, you may recognize it.
[ Music ]
The second movement is the
first of three recitatives sung
by the bass and Bach cantatas
and other vocal works,
the bass voice is often
associated with God
or vox Christi, and
this recitative
of God the bass emphasizes
God's law.
So, the bass will come in
"Gott gab uns ein Gesetz",
"God gave us a Law."
[ Music ]
The third movement is an aria
sung by the Tenor beginning
with the words, "Wir waren
schon zu tief gesunken".
"We were sunk too deep."
"Tiefe drohte schon den Tod",
"The deep already
threatened us with death."
You'll note the descending
somewhat tortured melodic lines
that represent sinking into
the depths of sin and a sort
of jig-like rhythm that is a
bit jaunty for the ominous text.
[ Music ]
I won't play a clip of
the fourth movement,
but it's again a
recitative sung by the bass,
"Doch muste das Gesetz
erfullet warden",
"But the law had
to be fulfilled."
The fifth movement is an
absolutely elegant Soprano
and Alto Aria, "Herr, du siehst
statt gutter Werke", "Lord,
instead of good works you look
at Auf des Herzens
Glaubensstarke",
"At the strength of
faith in our hearts."
It's actually a double canon
paring the flute and oboe
and the Soprano and Alto.
I'll play enough of it so
that you can hear both canons.
[ Music ]
The sixth movement is
a recitative, again,
in the bass expanding on God's
law, "When we recognize sin
through the law", "So schlagt
es das Gewissen nieder",
"Than conscience
strikes us down."
I'll move on to the
seventh and last movement.
It's a straightforward
four-part setting
of chorale tune which
is typical.
"Ob sichs anlies, als wollt
er nicht" "Although it seems
that he is unwilling", "Las
dich es nicht ershrecken",
"Do not be dismayed."
And we'll play the
whole chorale.
[ Music ]
You can understand why Bach
was so fond of this chorale
and used it in a
number of cantatas.
Now, how did this manuscript end
up in the Library of Congress?
I will read from the
library's annual report of 1931
where Carl Engel then Chief
of the Music Division,
gives the provenance
of the manuscript.
I really can't improve on what
he wrote, so I'll just read it.
"The most signal acquisition
by purchase for the year,
and indeed for many
years, is the original
and complete holograph score
of Johann Sebastian Bach's
Cantata 'Es ist das Heil uns
kommen her.'
It is the first Bach manuscript
of any importance that has come
to the library and there
are few in America today
to match it in extent
and rarity.
The purchase from the
widow of Dr. Wolffheim,
the distinguished
musicologist and collector
in Berlin was made possible
only through a fortunate joining
of forces, that is, through the
gifts of money from the friends
of music in the Library
of Congress
and the Beethoven Association
of New York combined
with the resources
of the library."
Now I'll skip to the provenance.
Nikolaus, "Johann
Nikolaus Forkel,
J.S. Bach's first
biographer wrote
to an unidentified
correspondent on April 4th,
1803 that at a time when
Wilhelm Friedemann Bach,
that's Bach's oldest son,
had been in particularly
reduced circumstances.
The latter it offered to
him for sale an entire year
of J.S. Bach's cantatas
about 69 works
in the composer's handwriting
for 20 [foreign word spoken],
but Forkel himself at the time
not being insufficient funds
to accept the offer, paid
2 [foreign word spoken]
for the privilege of
examining these manuscripts.
Taking advantage of the
opportunity, Forkel writes
that he copied some of the
finest of the cantatas belonging
to the set that Friedemann
had lent him.
Among the cantatas copied
was 'Es ist das Heil uns
kommen her.'
The whole set according
to Forkel,
was sold by Friedemann
before 1778
for 12 thaler" that's
t-h-a-l-e-r,
"or something like 9 dollars."
With all due respect
to Carl Engel,
I think he may be mistaken
about that or errored in that,
because I found a table
of the purchasing power
of various currencies that were
used in Germany at the time
of Bach and his sons,
and according
to this table 12 thaler would
have equaled 864 dollars
which is still a pittance
for 69 Bach manuscripts.
It remains to be established
who bought the holograph
from Friedemann.
The whereabouts of
this score was unknown
to Morris Helpmann
[assumed spelling]
when he prepared the
publication of the cantata
for the first volume of the
complete Bach edition in 1851.
To judge by the character of
the binding and French imprint
on the silk back of it, the
manuscript must have been
in French hands about the
middle of the last century.
The front cover has stamped
on it an English title.
The manuscript was acquired
by the late Dr. Wolffheim some
10 years ago from the firm
of Liepmannssohn, the
musical antiquarians in Berlin
who purchased it through
a private agent in 1921.
Mr. Liepmannssohn
offered the suggestion
that the English owner may
have been A. George Kurtz
of Liverpool whose important
autograph collection was
disbursed by sales in 1895
and the following years.
Here is the likely
provenance of the manuscript.
Bach, of course, was the
original owner and when he died
in 1750, it passed
to Friedemann.
When Bach died his manuscripts
and books were divided
among his four musical sons
and his little Anna Magdalena.
We know that it was in
possession of Friedemann in 1773
when Forkel saw it
and copied it out.
We suspect that it was
sold by 1778 or soon after,
because there is a stamped
letter from Friedemann
to family friend Johann Joachim
Eschenburg instructing him
to sell all his remaining
manuscripts.
As Friedemann put it,
"Convert them to cash."
There is speculation that it
may have been in French hands
in the middle of
the 19th-century.
At some point it was probably
acquired by Andrew George Kurtz,
a collector and critic
in Liverpool as suggested
by the Liepmannssohns
when they sold it
to Werner Wolffheim in 1921.
Wolffheim died in 1930 leaving
the manuscript to his widow.
The library bought it
from [foreign name
spoken] Wolffheim in 1931.
I located the Music Division's
order for the purchase
in 1931 which is on display.
It indicates that
Ossip Gabrilowitsch,
conductor of the Detroit
Symphony Orchestra from 1918
to 1935, made the
offer of the manuscript
to Carl Angle [assumed spelling]
on behalf of Mrs. Wolffheim.
Gabrilowitsch had toured
and even lived in Berlin
in the course of his
career and must have gotten
to know the Wolffheims.
Gabrilowitsch knew Carl
Angle as far back as 1917
and even Oscar [inaudible]
before
that having made many
requests to borrow
or have Photostats
made of scores
from the library's collections;
we don't do that anymore.
And in 1931, he and Angle
collaborated on a music festival
in the Coolidge Auditorium.
A few of the many letters
between Gabrilowitsch and Angle
that year mentioned the
negotiations surrounding
the manuscript.
He wrote as a postscript to a
letter to Carl Angle in 1931.
"Now, here is an
entirely different story.
Please read the enclosed
letter from my friend
and distinguished Berlin lawyer
Dr. Tiktim [assumed spelling]
and please tell me
whether you know of anybody
who might be interested
in buying the Bach
manuscript which he describes.
I would really appreciate
your advice in this matter."
And Gabrilowitsch wrote to
Carl Angle again May 5th,
1931 "In accordance with
our telephone conversation,
I shall make an effort
to ascertain as soon
as I reach Berlin what lowest
price Mrs. Wolffheim would
accept for the Bach manuscript.
You mentioned in your
conversation the other day,
that other cantatas
of Bach were for sale
in this country at present.
My request to you is only that
you do not commit yourself
to buy one of these other
manuscripts until you have heard
from me, as I am almost,
almost sure that Mrs. Wolffheim
will be most reasonable
in her demands."
And then on June 2nd,
Gabrilowitsch sent a telegraph
to Angle, "Mrs. Wolffheim,
willing to sell Bach
manuscript $5000, please cable."
That wraps up my story
on the manuscript
of Bach Cantata Number 9.
Thank you for your interest.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
There will be time a little
later to see the items up close
if you haven't seen
them already,
but first I'll turn the floor
over to my colleague Anne McLean
who will tell you a bit
about the manuscript
for Bach's Cantata
Number 10, as well as,
other items showing different
aspects of Bach's life and work.
>> Anne McLean: Good morning.
It's very touching
to be in the presence
of these magnificent
scores really.
To see the physical
manifestations of experiences
that hold such meaning
for us as music lovers,
and it can be memorable to
appreciate them physically
and anesthetically, and
certainly from the point-of-view
of handwriting and notational
calligraphy they are beautiful.
Today, about 805 of
Bach's manuscripts are held
in the Bach Archive in Leipzig.
And we are fortunate as Jan
says, to have these two.
It's remarkable really to see
them and to hold them here
at the Library of Congress.
In addition to the manuscripts
for these two sublime cantatas,
we've also brought out
for you a very small
and charming manuscript of his
French Suites for a keyboard,
the very small manuscript you
see on this side of the table.
This one is not in Bach's hand.
It was copied by his son-in-law
Johann Christoph Atnickol,
but it's quite significant as
a major source for the suites.
First we'll take a quick look
at an interesting artifact
from the late 1740s.
It places the composer in
a very earthly context.
Earlier you saw Jan had
that beautiful image
of the one Mendelssohn
watercolor
of the St. Thomas Church.
Here is an image of the
interior and a plaque with Bach
with the flowers as
you see in the floor.
This shows the organ and
gives you a sense of the space
in the church, so have a sense
of what he would
have been looking
at every day when
he was in there.
Bach's position gave him the
responsibility for the music
in Leipzig churches actually,
St. Thomas, St. Nicholas,
St. Mathew and St. Peters.
He himself directed at both
St. Thomas and St. Nicholas
and prefix handled the others.
He also supervised
the musical education
of the choir boys of
the Thomas School.
John Elliott Gardner has
written an extraordinary book,
"Music in the Castle of Heaven"
and one of the things he says
in there about the, he has a
lot about the cantatas in there,
how they are conceived
and used and so forth,
he says he thinks one reason
that Bach may have been
interested in writing these is
as chorale cantatas is because
it would help him literally
chorale and anchor the voice
of sopranos because it was
that each one, each cantata had
a song that they would know,
a hymn tune rather
that they would know.
So, we always think
of him working
with this 55-voice
choir, the Thomaner Choir.
Let's see a document that
takes us into the realm
of Bach's business life into
the mundane and quotidian round
of duties he had
as a Thomas cantor.
And this is something you'll see
on the table there,
the Nathan Bequest.
They are receipts in the
hand of Johann Sebastian Bach
and this is why we
had this title
for our presentation
today, "In His Hand;
Notes and Accounts by Bach."
We have a page, a
very small page
of Bach's handwritten
receipts for payments received
from the bequest for a wealthy,
the wife of a wealthy
[inaudible] cabinetmaker
for preparing and
conducting the choir
in an annual memorial service.
Each year on Sabina's
Day, October 26th,
the choir would perform
funeral motets
for this donor during
the service
at either St. Thomas
or St. Nicholas.
Sabinaton [assumed spelling]
widow of this cabinetmaker died
in 1612 and a 134 years later
this bequest was still being
honored annually.
Bach was the recipient of
this payment over a period
of 27 years and his
predecessors, of course,
for many years before that.
This receipt is part of the
library's Moldenhauer Archives,
it's a wide-ranging
collection of more
than 3500 items documenting
the history of western music.
Hans Moldenhauer was a noted
Alpine climber who immigrated
to the U.S. in 1938 and he also
wrote an important biography
of Anton Von Weber.
The library owns a major
part of his collection
and you can find an
extensive book about it online
if you would like our website.
Robert Marshall the
Bach scholar writes
that these receipts
were originally bound
into a big account book kept
by the cabinetmaker's gild
and as you can imagine, the ones
signed by Bach were extracted
and sold off over many years to
collectors like the one we have.
On [inaudible] and you'll be
able to turn it, we'll be able
to turn it over for you, on
recto are receipts for 1746
and 47 and then on
the verso at the top,
which is what you see
here, the one for 1748.
Below that, you see the
handwriting is different.
It's a partial receipt created
by Bach's son Johann
Christoph Bach for 1749.
He started to write this
for his father at age 14
and seeing this brings
the poignant realization
that he needed to do this,
because Bach was
losing his eyesight.
The amount of the, the amount
for the services rendered was 5
golden, with two going to Bach
and 3 going to the choir boys.
I believe this amount according
to Back documented book,
I believe this would
be around 75
to 80 dollars today, probably.
And Bach actually derived
a lot of his income
from these kinds of payments.
You know, of course, as any
church musician can tell you,
you do weddings and funerals and
these are part of your income.
He also was paid in things
like candles and oil,
heating oil and things
like that.
He had an income of about
700 thalers per year,
but he had all these
other small sources.
Now, let's take a look at
the little score I mentioned.
This is a manuscript of
Bach's French Suites,
the cover in red goat skin.
This was not the original cover.
It was part of his majesterial
group of keyboard works
from his late 30s including
"The Well-Tempered Clavier"
Goldberg Variations,
Italian Concerto and others.
This small score is a
very clear readable copy
of the French Suites BWV 812
through 816 made by his student
and son-in-law and it measures
less than 8 inches wide
and less than 6 inches high.
Something that you think
about when you look
at this appealing little book is
the platoon of excellent copyist
that Bach deployed, most
of them his students.
He also had a private secretary,
something you don't think
about with Bach for a number
of years in his later year,
later career, although,
very little of is correspondence
unfortunately have survived.
This manuscript was
originally thought
to be a Bach manuscript
in his own hand.
Phillip [foreign name spoken]
the biographer thought he could
authenticate it as such, and
in fact, we have a letter
about that, but as you've
seen this morning already
in the calligraphy, this
style is very different
or you will see in a moment.
These French Suites are a
little more modest in scope
than the English Suites and
I imagine several of you
that have played
both those sets;
how many of are pianist
or keyboard people?
That's what I figured.
These are a little shorter.
Sometimes described as
domestic or a little lighter
than the English
Suites and partitas.
They're less contrapuntal.
Wilhelm Friedemann's
Siete Sinfonia
and Willem de Vriend the ones
written for him I should say,
were more complex and
these do not have preludes.
Neither set was published
in Bach's lifetime.
He used these as teaching
pieces and like many of them,
like many of his compositions
including the Partitas flute
sonatas he revised
them extensively
over a considerable period.
Five of these Suites are
from 1722 from his years
in [foreign word spoken].
The last one probably written
in Leipzig a little later.
According to scholars, there
are at least 5 versions
of these Suites making it hard
to know what would be
the definitive version.
He copied them into 5 of them
into his wife's notebook,
the famous Clavier-Buchlein
of Anna Magdalena Bach.
The first of two she had and
the one that he gave her shortly
after they were married in 1721.
So, is there something
of Clavier that's
interesting for a quick look?
One thing is that the title page
does not say "French Suites."
It actually says, "Six
Suites" and then below
that a description of the
dance forms in German similar
to the title page, you
see on his partitas.
The French title that we see on
modern scores came much later,
12 years after Bach's death
from Friedrich Wilhelm Marpurg
and also his biographer Forkel.
Our manuscript copied
after 1744,
is the last chronologically
of the major sources for the
"French Suites" and
there were many sources.
Often performers choose
to collate their own
performing edition
and that's what Richard
Egarr did
who was here just a few
weeks back in January.
A lot of artists go back
to the source and look
at the manuscripts themselves
and collate and choose
and put together an
edition in which they like.
Our score, the point of
showing this today is
that our score is important
for a Bach Scholarship,
because it includes all six
suites and it is written,
it is copied in what is today
considered the correct order.
This score was one
of the sources
for the complete Bach edition.
So, how French are they?
In fact, not so very.
Many commentators talk about
the steel galant aspects
and French inflected melodies
and so on, but when you look
at the individuals suites,
you see both Italian
and French style
Courante movements
and quite an international
variety
of instrumental dance forms
including a Polish one,
"The Lure" you can see the
name up at the top at the left
and also an [inaudible] which
I believe is a form unique
to this source for Bach; his
only use of it I believe.
He wrote these at
Kurten, a princely court
where he was definitely exposed
to all kinds of dance movements
at musical conventions from
the continent and elsewhere.
When you look at this display
later, this volume is opened
to the Sarabande of the Fifth
Suite and is a rare chance
to see Bach's own ornamentation.
Generally in terms of ornaments,
there are very few indicated
in any of his scores.
The thinking player,
a sophisticated musician would
have created his own ornaments
of course, according to the
taste and style of the day
and his own instincts.
Bach would have been surprised
to see modern editions
with many ornaments
carefully indicated.
There's one other rather
esoteric point that's fun
to make or interesting
to make based
on this particular Bach source;
I looked at Ruth Tatlow's book
"God's Numbers" which makes
an interesting and strong case
for Bach using revisions,
even revisions
to what are essentially finished
manuscripts to bring his works
into the realm of symbolism.
She calls her theory
"proportional parallelism",
basing it on concepts
about proportions
of universal harmony, physical,
moral, and philosophical harmony
that reflected God's creation.
And she believes that
he tinkered carefully
with final copies of his
work to bring them into line
with mathematical
concepts of proportion.
Quote "Probably [foreign
name spoken] version has been
numerically revised in pursuit
of numerical perception."
That's our copy.
Her book has a number
of charts including one
that shows a total count of 1380
written bars for this manuscript
in support of her theory
which reflects divine design;
interesting, though maybe you
might like to check it out.
Now let's turn to the Cantata,
"Meine Seel erhebt den Herren",
"My soul that magnify the Lord."
This Cantata is for the feast of
the visitation of Mary performed
for the first time
on July 2nd, 1724,
probably not performed
again until, after 1740.
The German text is based on
the story of the visitation
of the Virgin Mary to her cousin
Elizabeth and the prefiguring
of the birth of Christ.
Bach's Chorale Cantatas were
written on text composed
by librettists generally
and these actually had
to be reviewed and
approved by senior clerics
in the Lutheran Church
before he could set them,
before he was able to
go ahead and do them.
That's a new fact from me again
from this fascinating book.
But for this cantata, the
opening chorus is taken
from Luke 1 verse 46:48 which
are familiar to many people.
"Oh my soul praised the Lord.
How my spirit rejoices
in God my savior."
The fifth movement
used the verse 54,
"He has helped his
servant Israel
and remembered to be merciful."
This cantata does not a
traditional chorale or hymn tune
from Lutheran Church as
it's musical foundation.
It uses "The German
Magnificat" that you hear
in the Vespers' liturgy.
It seems to resemble
a reciting tone
and it carries a melodic
hint of connections to chant
and to modal harmony that
give it an archaic character,
slight archaic character.
The cantata has seven movements
with and overall tonality
of G major, sorry, G minor.
In the opening of chorus, which
we'll hear in just a moment,
you'll hear the [foreign
word spoken],
the foundational melody
first in the sopranos
and then in the altos.
I wanted to show you this blank
page, the second of the page
of the manuscript,
because it shows you
that Bach made his own score
and probably everyone did
in those days, manuscript
paper was very expensive.
He had a rostrum which is
those fork-like implements
that you draw across the page
and apparently he used some
of them until they were worn out
and you can see there are spaces
and they're not, sometimes
they're not even any equal,
you know, the lines
are not equal.
But, he worked, he made his own
scores and he had three types
of ink which we'll
talk about in a moment.
There, I said, there
are seven movements,
a chorus "Meine Seel
erhebt den Herren;
soprano Aria [foreign word
spoken] bass aria, a duet.
A beautiful duet which has
the full chorale melody,
we'll hear in a moment
pointed out by the trumpet.
[Foreign word spoken] and final
chorus which uses also a bit
of the, uses the
doxology at the end.
So, Mike let's play this opening
chorus just for a moment.
You'll hear the trumpet
right away.
[ Music ]
So, written, this was written
for soprano, alto, tenor,
and bass soloists an SATB chorus
with an accompanying ensemble
of trumpet, two oboes, two
violins, viola, and contiuo
and the trumpet which you
heard is very appropriate
for this cantata, because
during the Baroque period it was
associated with the
concept of divine majesty.
The parts for this
manuscript score are held
in the Leipzig Bach Archive.
Parts and scores were often
separated by the family
after his death with
the thinking
that the works themselves
might be better preserved
than if they were kept
everything by one party.
Basaki Suzuki [assumed
spelling] made the point to us
when he looked at
this score with us
that he felt one
could learn much more
from the parts than
from the score.
Scores as we can see with this
one have very few markings
for [foreign word spoken],
very few for articulation and,
in fact, they are, they're
rather bare bones compared
to what you see in
the parts in terms
of bowings and things like that.
Here, in fact, for our score
the instrumentation is not even
notated on this score
proper, it's in the rapport
of the folios surrounding
the music.
I wanted to mention that
this score is now avail;
actually both cantatas
are now available
in very handsome reproductions
from the [foreign word spoken],
both with an excellent preface
by our former colleague Dan
Boomhauer [assumed spelling].
Before we begin, Mike let's
hear a bit of the duet
of the alto and tenor.
It's a beautiful piece and the
way the chorale is treated,
melody is treated is very nice.
[ Music ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Before looking at a couple of
details from the manuscript
which are really instructive,
let's look at the
provenance for a moment.
Gertrude Clarke Whittall
who donated this pavilion
and this Strauss which is
Stradivarius instruments
which you see here, gave the
funds to make this purchase.
So, this manuscript
is not a part
of the Whittall Foundation
Collection.
It's been owned by
a fascinating group
of notable owners including
first Wilhelm Friedemann Bach,
then Philipp Spitta the
19th-century Bach biographer.
His work was very significant
for his time and, in fact,
was almost unbudgeable
for generations afterwards even
though his information was often
later not proved so reliable.
Carl Pistor, an inventor and
collector bought the manuscript
and gave it to his daughter
Betty who was a friend
of Felix Mendelssohn's,
and later the mining
magnet Carl Bechstein,
the father of the
philosopher Ludwig Beshstein,
and his son Paul was a
pianist who was known
for having created a significant
rapport for a piano left hand;
you may have heard about him.
He lost his arm during the First
World War and Revell and Straus
and a number of people
wrote works for him.
He continued to tour
as a pianist
for quite a number of years.
He immigrated to the
U.S. in the late 1930s
and he brought some
family valuables
with him including a
number of music manuscripts
which remained in this country.
His sister Margaresia, married
an American psychiatrist named
Jerome Stoneburrow [assumed
spelling] who was a colleague
of Freud's and lived in
Vienna for a longtime.
It was her son, John
H. Stoneburrow
who sold our manuscript
to a former music division
chief Harold Spivak in 1948.
So, it's a colorful history
when you read about it.
It's rather sad the family was
just estranged from each other
and there some acrimony
over the manuscripts,
but this how it came to
the Library of Congress.
So, regarding this manuscript,
there it tells us a lot
of things that is really fun to
look at and we'll just have time
to look at them quickly
here, a few items.
Bach, as we know, was incredibly
industrious and very meticulous
and he worked very quickly.
In a composing score like the
two cantata manuscripts we have,
you see he sometimes
works with just soprano
and bass and fills in later.
Sometimes he completes
the full score pressing on
and sometimes even
continuing in mid thought.
The sheer volume of this
tremendous output meant
that he was always
writing under pressure
and we've talked a little bit
about how many works
he was doing.
At one point I think in
1723 he had something
like 9 works completed
to be done in 16 days
for a big Christmas celebration.
And he revised his
work constantly.
This is something
that you will read
about in many studies,
Bach studies.
Within a composition
he revised them,
while working he
revised them and then
when revisiting them he
made constant revisions,
sometimes much later.
Throughout his life this was a
practice and also, as we know,
borrowing from himself
and repurposing material
from one work to another
or to several works.
On this page that we're looking
at, see the part in tiny writing
at the very bottom, that there
are three, four empty staves
and they you see
sort of sketched
out something a little faintly,
a less, little less hard
in terms of bearing down on
the ink, than the pen rather.
This is, he is thinking and
revising at the same time.
He wrote in this phrase as
a kind of an aide memoire
to hold his musical
thought while the ink dried
like a little to-do
note for himself,
but he was also revising
certainly, because when you look
at the next page you can
also see, you see up here
in the middle of the page,
near where it says "page 2"
in revisions, you can see that
he has continued that thought
with those phrases, but they're
a little different already
by the time he had
turned the page.
And a lot of people
talk about this,
because he apparently worked at
a desk with three types of ink,
black, sepia, and a powder that
he would stir water together
with a copper gallic powder.
He made his own ink.
Anyway, he had an inkwell
there and he would have to wait
until the ink had dried before
he could go on, and sometimes,
this process would take maybe
5 to 6 minutes they say.
There was a box of sand on
his desk, very find sand
and he would have sprinkled
over heavy ink passages
to make them dry
faster, but nonetheless,
it took a while for
this to happen.
So, what you will find when you
look at these manuscripts is
that he did indeed
change a few things
when he continued even
on a one-page later.
So, let's see this is the
page two of, or sorry,
this is the soprano aria
and at the bottom you see there
are three crossed out staves.
This is another section
where he was sort of working
out his thoughts and he
actually, the same thing
when you have the chance to go
through there you'll
actually see
that what he has begun here
is not quite exactly what you
would expect.
It's a little different.
The next page, this
one is interesting
because it shows how he used
the manuscript pages of space
that he had available
to him, meaning you see
in the middle there are
these kind of little,
I don't know what you,
tadpole-like figures upside-down
tadpoles, he just kind
of made little notations
to himself,
he didn't write it all out.
But he's backing this up
against other parts of the piece
and he's just basically,
you know,
continuing right along he
knows what he has in mind
and so forth, so
these kinds of usages
of joining sections together
it economizing on paper
and barreling through in a way
to get his ideas onto the paper.
These are all very
indicative of his style.
We find it astonishing
today the number
of what are considered
masterpieces that he created
on a steady schedule for the
yearly church calendar some 300
cantatas plus, of course,
the many larger works.
Actually, it was common for
cantors to write annual cycles
of 60 works and I read that
Telemann wrote more than 1700
and Graupner more than 1400,
both of whom were offered
the Leipzig position before
Bach actually.
But the level of writing
and musical thinking,
the mastery of these works
is at a far higher level.
So, let's hear the final
chorale with the doxology
and then we'll just have
a moment about the ink.
Yeah, this is the chorale page.
[ Music ]
So, a word about
the preservation
of the manuscripts
and about the ink.
He used something called iron
gall ink often in this kind
of an aubergine color, it
has come to that color today.
It's a heavy ink with a lot
of tannin an oak substance
from those oak balls that
you see and lots of minerals,
a combination that today is
unfortunately rather deleterious
to the health of these
manuscripts and we know
that many, many of
them are deteriorating
at the Bach Archive too.
If you know of any Silicon
Valley tech moguls who would
like to underwrite preservation
of Bach manuscripts it would be
an extraordinary gesture to try
and find a way to preserve them,
but you can see here at the top
and elsewhere where the ink
is concentrated and blobs are.
When you pick up the ink to
write, the minerals apparently,
the heavier minerals
dripped off under the papers
so they caused some
of the blobs.
Today, those blobs are literally
eating away the manuscripts.
Fortunately, here at the library
we have expert conservators
in our Conservation Department
who are have been able to work
with these manuscripts,
as you see,
they are handsomely preserved
and they have done a number
of things to them, for example,
bathing them in a warm bath
of calcium, magnesium,
magnate, yeah magnesium
and putting rice starch
into the binding and so on.
If they were not preserved
in the Mylar they probably
couldn't really be viewed
and other museums and libraries
sometimes put them under glass.
So, we are lucky
that we have these
that you can actually
turn the pages
and I encourage you
very much to do
that when you're
looking at them.
It's a privilege to have
these in our collections
and a privilege to
show them to you today,
and it makes seeing them with
you, makes me think of a quote
that I found from a man
named Otto Bettmann,
"Bach's music sets in
order what life cannot."
So, please come up
and take a look.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.